bonsoir yves d'amécourt merci direct sur
rt france alors avant d'évoquer ses
alliances un sondage 52 % des français
n'ont pas l'intention d'aller voter au
second tour de ces municipales c'est ce
qui ressort d'un sondage yougov pour
l'ops
aujourd'hui au premier tour à on
rappelle que la participation s'est
établie à seulement 44 66 %
une réaction ce qu'il fallait maintenir
vraiment ces municipales à 1 le débat
avait eu lieu à l'époque à notre avis
est qu'il ne fallait pas le maintenir
d'ailleurs nous avons déposé un référé
liberté auprès du conseil d'état qui
sera jugé demain pour expliquer que ce
deuxième tour en pleine crise du corona
virus est en plein état d'urgence
puisque le premier ministre a annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'il envisageait de
prolonger l'état d'urgence au-delà du 10
juillet n'était pas raisonnable et que
cela entraînerait un fort taux
d'abstention puisqu'un certain nombre de
gens dont la santé est fragile ou qui
sont des personnes à risque qui n'iront
pas voter même si le parlement est en
train de voter une loi pour assouplir le
système des procurations
ce qui fait que les gens pourront
préparer leur vote contrairement au
premier tour où ils ont été mis devant
le fait accompli
ce deuxième tour de scrutin sera
forcément un scrutin avec une forte
abstention et c'est dommage puisque les
élections municipales sont les élections
préféré des français est donc une
nouvelle fois on met un coup de canif
dans le suffrage universel qui est
pourtant au coeur de notre système
démocratique
alors on peut se demander quand on vous
écoute et dans ces conditions quand on
voit ce sondage si le gouvernement est
vraiment attaché à ce qu'il y ait une
forte participation
exactement se pose on se pose vraiment
la question et c'est dommage parce que
on a bien vu dans les crises la crise du
corona virus ou dans la crise des gilets
jaunes que la base de la pyramide
démocratique ce sont les maires ce sont
des conseils municipaux sont les
hussards de la république ce sont des
héros du quotidien et que en défaisant
ce scrutin des élections municipales ou
en leu leu en en changeant la la qualité
est bien on est en train de toucher à
cette pyramide qui fait vraiment le la
fondation de notre l'organisation de la
nation
ce sont pour vous des élections
sacrifier d'une certaine manière oui des
élections sacrifier des élus sacrifier
alors maintenant les questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalité sont
au conseil constitutionnel jusqu'à
aujourd'hui 3 juin les mémoires en
intervention pouvait être remis au
conseil constitutionnel l'association 50
millions d'électeurs a remis un mémoire
en intervention pour redire une fois de
plus tout ce qui avait manqué à ce
premier tour des élections municipales
et tout ce qui manquera au second alors
on va parler maintenant des alliances
ces accords d'appareil
alors ils sont forts commandes pour les
politiques
est ce que ce n'est pas le pire signal
que l'on puisse envoyer aux électeurs
dans un climat évidemment de défiance
entre les français et leurs responsables
politiques
effectivement les électeurs n'y
comprennent plus grand chose il est
coutume de dire au premier tour on
choisit au deuxième tour on élimine est
donc aujourd'hui face à une coalition du
parti socialiste et europe écologie les
verts parfois de la france insoumise
il est logique que le centre la
république en marché des républicains
salies c'est ce qui s'est passé à
bordeaux c'est ce qui s'est passé à lyon
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans un certain
nombre de villes mais c'est vrai que les
électeurs ne comprennent pas grand chose
puisque aujourd'hui l'opposition
raisonnable à la république en marche au
parlement au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale ce sont les républicains et
donc bien sûr la politique locale ce
n'est pas la politique nationale mais
c'est très compliqué d'expliquer aux
gens sur le terrain qu'on peut être
opposé au niveau national et alliés au
niveau local vous disiez c'est assez
logique
je sais pas le terme exact que vous avez
employé ces alliances entre la
république en marche et l air vous
trouvez ça justement logique quand on
voit la situation nationale ça semble
assez
la chronique finalement c'est
anachronique mais au niveau local je
pense que il ya un plus grand danger
pour les villes qui serait de donner le
pouvoir à l'alliance entre les
écologistes des altermondialistes et
puis la gauche de la gauche puisque ce
qui reste du parti socialiste
aujourd'hui c'est celle à gauche de la
gauche et donc b face à cette union de
la gauche il ya un réflexe logique et
normal qu'ils aient de d'allier le
centre avec la droite même si c'est
compliqué à expliquer sur le terrain
alors le pari et qui évidemment va être
scrutée un plus grandes villes de france
la capitale anne hidalgo qui va
certainement s'allier aux verts pari
gagnant pour pour la mer sans faire
finalement de trop de concessions je
pense que il ya un grand risque pour
paris et alors tout va se jouer dans la
mobilisation et dans la participation au
deuxième tour
moi je crois assez aux chances de
rachida dati de l'emporter surtout que l
a réussi à faire l'union sur son
discours et sur sa campagne ce qui
n'était pas derrière elle au premier
tour le son au second et donc je suis
assez confiant pour le score de rachida
dati
le fait qu'elle ait refusé justement
agnès buzyn la main tendue de rachida
dati c'est un handicap pour elle selon
vous ça ne va finalement pas pesé
je crois que le handicap c'est agnès
buzyn dans cette crise du coronavirus au
ministère de la santé les déclarations
qu'elle a fait avant et après sa sortie
du gouvernement ne joue pas en sa faveur
l'espèce de suspense autour de sa
candidature qui n'était pas souhaitée et
qui finalement a été validée parce que
plus personne ne veut y aller à la
république en marche qu'en fait cette
élection va être perdu pour la
république en marche
et donc voilà agnès buzyn c'est un atout
pour personne est ce que vous vous
attendez à des surprises lors de ce
scrutin
il ya toujours des surprises et les
surprises elles viendront de la
participation ou non au premier tour il
ya des listes qui se sont retrouvés avec
des scores importants parce qu'un
certain nombre d'électeurs non ont été
empêchés de voter
est ce que ses électeurs qui n'ont pas
voté au premier tour se déplaceront au
second ça peut faire bouger les lignes
et puis on a aussi la crise du
coronavirus qui joue en faveur des
formations politiques souverainistes et
altermondialiste est ce que ça se
traduira en bulletins dans les urnes
c'est des choses qu'il faut qu'il faut
voir et qu'il faudra analyser le moment
venu merci beaucoup yves d'amécourt vice
président de l'association 50 millions
d'électeurs conseiller régional lr
région nouvelle aquitaine d'avoir été
avec nous